hardest in the way that I explain things
to kind of explain how it is and what
it's like more of the intent of giving
someone who's never used it an
understanding of the substance instead
of trying to encourage someone to do it
oh I got to do this
[Music]
God damn
you're right okay
I'm not [__] around when did you
first find a friend named cocaine and
like I said I'm not trying to Advocate
it I loved it but it's death to me
that's why I can't [__] with it I agree
with you
I cannot do enough [__] [__] stop stop
I was on Tinder like three three four
weeks ago right and like I was just
messaging girls like they're [__]
smoke math you know like like whatever
drugs
I mean I I don't know
foreign